-My name is Janet
Rich-Edwards and I
am one of co-directors
of the science program
here at the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Studies.
Thank you for coming out
on a gray and drizzly day.
I think you're going
to get a treat.
We have tonight coming from the
Norwegian University of Science
and Technology in
Trondheim Dr. Linn
Getz who is the professor
in behavioral sciences
and medicine there.
The reason we have Linn is
because of a conversation
she and I had at her house in
Trondheim about a year ago,
which was one of the most
stimulating conversations
I have had in a long time about
medicine, social medicine,
precision medicine, and
who will get access to it,
and how can it maximize
the health of populations.
And I thought, wow, it would
be great to bring Linn here.
And it was Linn's idea to
bring Bruce along as well,
up from Rockefeller University.
Bruce McEwen, who is somewhat
of a household name around here.
If you think allostatic
load, you think Bruce McEwen.
He is the Alfred
Mirsky Professor
at the Hatch Laboratory
of Neuroendicronology
at Rockefeller.
Dr. McEwen discovered
adrenal steroid receptors
in the hippocampus in
1969 that really opened up
the gateway for all
sorts of studies
on circulating stress
hormones, sex hormones,
cognitive function,
mood regulation,
and other central systems
via epigenetic mechanisms.
If you don't know
what those are,
I'm sure you will by
the end of the hour.
He's a member of the
MacArthur Foundation research
network on socioeconomic
status and health.
So really studying the
distribution of health
and disease in society.
And he is on the
National Scientific
Council on the
Developing Child, which
focuses on biological embedding
of early life experiences
and promoting healthy
brain development.
So I think what we're going
to do is have Linn start out,
and then Bruce, and then Linn
will finish us up at the end.
So Lynn, why don't
you come on up.
Thank you. [APPLAUSE]
-Thank you Janet.
I'm so proud to be here.
This is quite a place for me.
And I'm a little nervous.
If you hear it, it's correct.
Here is the slide
I prepared for us
before I came, because I didn't
know you had such a good slide.
And here you can see the
whole spectrum of the topic
from thinking at the left, to
multi-billion data measurements
to the right hand side,
and everything between.
Thank you so much for making
it possible to get here
and also for having the
opportunity to meet Bruce.
We have been communicating by
e-mail and Skype since 2009.
And now finally we met
yesterday in person,
and it has been already a treat
and it hasn't stopped yet.
I come from Trondheim.
It's a university city
in the middle of Norway.
And sometimes it feels
like in the middle nowhere.
[LAUGHTER] Here we go.
I used to be a
general practitioner.
That's a family physician.
I used to travel in
the north of Norway
with a boat going to visit
people in the islands.
I met lots of regular people.
I've also worked a
lot in psychiatry,
which I did in Iceland.
And now I'm back at the
university in Trondheim.
And Norway, as
you may know, it's
a social democratic
welfare state.
It's not a socialist
country even
though I think the
Americans don't really
make a difference there.
We do.
And we also have, for
practical purposes,
we do have equal
access to health care.
It's not perfect at all times.
But we do have it and it works.
And I know that's different
from what you have here.
This is my city Trondheim.
It was founded in
997 by a Viking King.
And through the
Middle Ages it was
famous as a site of pilgrimage.
People actually
walked through Europe
to get to this site of
healing and salvation.
It's the church above
St. Oluf's the saint.
And now we have a
St. Oluf's Hospital.
That's the new site where
people seek healing.
And the Faculty of Medicine.
And our little general practice,
or family medicine research
unit, is actually located
exactly at the outskirts
as you can see.
A little inside, a little
outside of mainstream medicine.
And this is my office.
And I have a view from my window
and I see some things there
which I would like
to share with you.
Of course medicine
has lots of successes,
but it's not why I
stand here today.
I don't want to debate that.
But there are also some areas
of remarkable stagnation.
For instance, an epidemic of
so-called medically unexplained
symptoms, or MUS, or even MUPS,
when it's physical symptoms.
My tentative diagnosis
of that epidemic
is that there is too much
doing and too little thinking
in medicine.
If you want to study medicine
in Norway you Google around
and you can see what
medicine looks like.
And at our university
this is the first sentence
describing the curriculum.
"To become a physician, you need
to know the body's machinery
right down to the
smallest cell."
And I think some of
the thinking problems
are actually rooted here, the
body machinery, that metaphor.
It can bring you to success, but
it can also bring you astray.
We did have a
success recently when
we got our faculty-- I had
nothing to do with that--
the Nobel Prize for medicine
and physiology in 2014.
It doesn't often go to Norway.
It quite often goes to
Harvard or Rockefeller.
But we got it for
the brains GPS,
the metaphor of the neurons
that make you orient yourself
in space.
What is even more
interesting from my window
is to see the
groundbreaking evidence
of the interrelatedness of
human biology and biography.
And whilst we are getting ever
more knowledge about this,
and insight, and it pours
out, the machine metaphor,
it is starting to rust.
But I cannot hear anything
but the engines still roar out
there.
We are doing so much of
the old fashioned stuff.
And I wonder when are we going
to start turning this huge tank
ship to another direction.
And whilst all of
this is happening
there is a persistent
tension and suspicion
between the humanistic and
the techno-scientific camps
in medicine.
But what is happening
is that the word person
is coming up in both those
camps somehow independently
of each other.
The word person is a
buzz word and cells.
Here you have the
humanistic version
exemplified by the European
Society for Person Centered
Health Care,
established in 2014.
And you can see here it says
it's a humanistic project.
And it's symbolized
by the human hand.
And I have for myself
added the thinker,
just to make sure that this is
a critically thinking movement.
But then on the other
side, in the other camp,
you have something called,
for instance, the Personalized
Medicine Coalition.
And that is quite another
story, with other metaphors.
Here you have the high
tech metaphor going.
And this has several names.
Personalized medicine
is where it started.
And that is what people
want to call it in Norway.
They don't want to
skip the word person.
But in the United States
and with President Obama
you are a little clever,
I think because you
choose the word
precision medicine, which
is much closer to
what it's all about.
It doesn't have much
to do with persons.
That's my whole point.
Sometimes it's
called P4 medicine.
I don't want to go
into exactly what all
those P's stands for,
personalized, participatory,
and all this.
Systems medicine is another
name for something very similar.
And the whole point, we
are dealing with billions
of data points or big data.
As you can see from
this avatar figure
that I stole from the
internet somewhere.
Now my big question that I
really play with these days,
is how might this renaissance
of the person concept
affect clinical
medicine in general.
And particularly family
medicine or primary health care
at the very front line where
normal suffering people
meet the health care system.
And of course I'm thinking from
a Nordic perspective, where
we try to have
equal access and we
have to think about
sustainability and cost,
because we don't want
to leave anybody behind.
If medicine is flying
decently high today.
We do many good things.
I wonder how it's going
to be 20 years from now.
And I have two scenarios,
the best case scenario
and the worst case scenario.
The best case scenario looks
like this the flying eagle.
I think we have fantastic
opportunities now
with this new knowledge that
Bruce will share some of it
with you.
But we also have a potential
worst case scenario.
We can get trapped in
this new knowledge.
And we can lose sight
of where we're actually
going, because
high tech makes it
possible to monitor
everything known to man
and a little more than that.
So a couple of years
ago Bruce invited
me to come in and
co-author a paper
that he was working with
called "Lifetime experiences,
the brain and
personalized medicine--
An integrative perspective."
And it's quite a mixture of
his world and my world as a GP,
or family physician.
And it's part of the
project that we are playing
with on Skype and email.
So I think I will stop now and
leave the next minutes for you
Bruce.
And you take us into your world.
And I hope that this
audience will appreciate
as much as I have done, all
the knowledge that you are so
generously sharing with
people who don't know much
about the brain.
-Thank you.
-So there you go.
Thank you very much Linn.
It's such a wonderful pleasure
to finally meet you in person
and have this opportunity.
This is really a
highlight for me.
And so yes, I'm
going to tell you
a little bit about
my journey into this.
Of course, I'm at the
Rockefeller University.
I've been there since
1966 on the faculty.
I was a student there.
I will tell you more about it.
Now Rockefeller has no
departments, only laboratories.
And so it's been easier
for me and others
to do research across
biomedical disciplines.
And in my case expanding out to
include the social sciences as
well.
My own progression was to be
a student of Vincent Allfrey
and Alfred Mirksy, who were
actually one of the first
to discover that
histones are modified
to regulate gene expressions.
I've known about this
thing we call epigenetics,
even though it didn't have
that term, since the 1960s.
And then I went to Sweden.
I had a two year
post-doctoral fellow
in the laboratory of a man
named Holger Hyden in Goteborg.
And I discovered
the hippocampus.
I didn't know much
about brain anatomy,
but it was a structure
that was easy to find.
When I came to
Rockefeller, and then went
to the laboratory
of Neil Miller,
who was a pioneer in what is
called behavioral medicine.
He was certainly
interested in stress.
We serendipitously discovered
that it was the hippocampus
and not the hypothalamus
that had receptors
is for stress hormones
for adrenal steroids.
And that's what started my
progression, almost inexorable
progression towards what
we're talking about today.
I was lucky enough to
meet the late Elliot
Stellar, a physiological
psychologist who introduced me
to interdisciplinary research
and got me into the MacArthur
Foundation Network, the
Health and Behavior Network,
the Successful Aging one
I didn't work in exactly,
but my colleague Teresa
Seaman started there--
and then the Network
on Socioeconomic Status
and Health, and now the
National Scientific Council
on the Developing Child.
So somehow the idea that
the brain as we will see
is the central organ
of stress and responds
to epigenetic signals.
This I got off the internet,
since people hardly
understand what it means, this
is not genetics, epigenetics.
Well, as you probably
know, it refers
to above the genome,
things currently
that regulate gene
expression, and development,
and throughout the life course
without actually changing
the DNA sequence.
Now originally, when
a man named Wattington
used the term
epigenetics it referred
to the emergence of
characteristics from,
say compare legged frogs
egg and human fertilized
egg that look very similar.
Well, the characteristics of the
species and even the individual
begin to appear.
And you couldn't have predicted
them from the previous stage.
So that was the original term.
Now epigenetics refers
to a whole series
of changes, the methylation
of cytosine bases on DNA,
which is in many cases
a reversible process.
The histones, which allow the
winding, unwinding, and winding
of the DNA, so it can either
be read and transcribed
or repressed and
not transcribed.
And there are other
mechanisms that are emerging.
So what is ironic is that it
wasn't too many years ago when
the people who sequenced
the human genome said,
now we know everything.
And there are still people who
operate only in terms of genes.
A recent paper in
Nature Biotechnology
didn't mention the
environment once
in talking about
gene interactions.
But we know that environment
is hugely important.
And of course, the other message
from the inexorable progression
of development is that we
can't turn back the clock.
We have to talk about resilience
and redirection and not
reversal.
So neuroendocrinology,
as I've practiced it,
involves the idea that hormones
affect all brain functions
and not just the
steroid hormones,
the metabolic hormones as
well, that experiences affect
the brain and the body
through these mechanisms,
and that behavior
changes the brain.
And one story in this whole
idea of integrative medicine,
there's a program at Cornell
Medical School next door
to Rockefeller, headed by a
woman named Mary Charleston.
And I was invited to give
the integrative medicine
grand rounds in the Department
of Medicine several years ago.
And after the talk I went
to, as the speakers do,
to morning report, and
there were two residents
who were presenting
a case of a woman who
came in with an acute autoimmune
and inflammatory disorder.
And they proceeded to
talk about the drugs, that
by and large did not work
very well for her condition.
And finally I stuck
out my hand and I said,
so what was her condition
when she came in?
Well, she had just learned that
her son had Hodgkin's disease.
They may or may not have
sent her to a social worker
to help with the
problem, but they
didn't mention this
as a primary factor
and present it as it was
a factor in how they then
went about treating her.
And this just indicates
the siloization
and the lack of regard
for this lived experience
that Linn introduced us to
and we'll talk about further.
So this is the diagram from
this New England Journal
article in 1998 talking about
the central role of the brain.
And I want to take
you through some steps
in explaining this diagram.
First, the concept that
we call allostatic load.
The idea that allostasis
is the active process
of putting out cortisol
and other mediators that
help us adapt.
And that's the purpose
of these mediators,
it's not damage, but adaptation.
But when there's
too much stress,
and when these responses
are dysregulated
then a allostatic load, or wear
and tear on the body and brain
can develop.
So, for example, cortisol,
when it's put out acutely
it actually enhances
immune function
and promotes energy
replenishment, certain kinds
of memory that keep
us away from danger
if we remember where danger
lay, promoting more efficient
cardiovascular function.
But chronically we
know that it suppresses
inflammation, suppresses
immune function,
can promote bone mineral
loss and muscle wasting,
and contribute to the
metabolic syndrome.
So we talk about an
inverted U. And you
will see inverted U shape
dose response curve again
in the talk.
Now cortisol is not
the only mediator.
It works together with the
parasympathetic and sympathetic
pro and anti-inflammatory
cytokines,
the other adrenal steroid
DHEA, a little bit
of oxidative stress, which is
important for cell functioning,
and it simultaneously
affects multiple systems
of the body, related to the
things you see on the slide.
And as a result of the fact
that these mediators interact
with each other and influence
each other's activity,
it's non-linear, and,
as I said, biphasic.
And it can be the
dysregulation that
can lead to allostatic
load can be related
to an unhealthy lifestyle
including poor sleep,
but exposure also
to toxic chemicals,
and these feed into this
network of allostasis.
For example, elevating
inflammation,
which then leads to an elevation
of cortisol, which then
can have adverse
consequences if both stay
elevated for long
periods of time.
And so these dysregulation,
the allostatic load,
is connected to disorders
in various systems and parts
of the body, from
mental health disorders
to immunologic disorders,
to cardiovascular disorders,
and metabolic disorders.
And we know and
you'll hear much more
from Linn about
co-morbidity's of diseases.
So I've already
mentioned lifestyle
and being stressed out.
Our health behaviors, whether
we lose sleep at night,
eat too many of the wrong
things, drink too much alcohol,
smoke, and so forth, or neglect
our regular moderate exercise,
these things also play into
this network of allostasis
and can contribute
to allostatic load.
We have of course different
kinds of stressors, trauma
and abuse, major
life events, but also
the daily environmental
stressors of our daily lives
at work, at home, in
our neighborhoods,
and watching television
in the evening
and seeing what's
happening in the world.
And if we talk about stressors,
and this is terminology
that's come out of the
National Scientific
Council of the
Developing Child, we
can talk about positive
stress, like giving a talk,
taking a challenge, and
having a positive outcome.
And to do that you have to
have a good sense of yourself.
A good mastery and
sense of control
to make the right choices,
to take the right risks.
There's tolerable stress,
where something bad happens,
a major life event.
You have the good
internal resources
and you have good material
and social support.
And you can weather the storm.
There may be some allostatic
load that results,
but it can be attenuated.
And then you have
toxic stress, which
involves a lack of
sense of control,
possibly because of poor
social and emotional support,
but also perhaps because of
compromised brain architecture
because of early
life experiences,
and we'll come to that shortly.
So the brain is indeed the
primary target of stress.
And this has been
work that we have done
and are doing ongoing
in the laboratory.
And I'll tell you just a
very little bit about it,
involving three different brain
structures, the hippocampus,
where we first discover
these preceptors.
And we know the hippocampus
is important for contextual,
and episodic, and
spatial memory,
but also it should be on this
slide for emotional regulation
and mood regulation.
The amygdala is involved
in fear, and anxiety,
and aggression.
It also turns on the autonomic
and hormonal stress response
just as the hippocampus
helps to shut it off.
The prefrontal cortex is
important for decision making,
for working memory,
and for all manner
of self-regulatory behaviors.
And it has downstream
influences on the amygdala
to keep it from
overreacting and interacts
with all of these
other brain structures.
And it helps to shut off the
autonomic and hormonal stress
response.
So if anything happens
to the architecture
of these individual
brain areas it's
going to affect the balance of
how they relate to one another.
And that's what
we'll talk about,
because one of the discoveries
growing over the last 30
or so years is that
even in adults as well
as the developing brain neurons
are capable of what we call
remodeling, that dendrites
can grow or shrink dependent
with experience.
That in the middle
synapses, these
are excitatory synapses
on what are called spines,
that there's a certain
turnover of some
of them, at least
every day, mediated
by the circadian cycle, which
helps you in motor learning.
And cortisol is very
important in those changes.
And that there is a certain
amount of neurogenesis
that actually occurs in
the dentate gyrus region
of the hippocampal formation.
This was a revelation some
decades ago, some of which
occurred in my
laboratory, and also
previously in the laboratory
for Fernando Nottebohm
at Rockefeller.
Elizabeth Gould, who is now
a professor at Princeton,
was the one who really
rediscovered neurogenesis
in the hippocampus.
And now it's a big
deal in relation
to lots of things going on in
understanding brain adaptation.
So we come back to our inverted
u-shaped dose response curve.
And talking only about,
just for the moment,
about cortisol and these
excitatory amino acid
transmitters that
are so important
for cognitive function, turning
on an acute stress response,
it actually helps
enhances excitability,
improves memory functions
as I said before.
But then if there is a
more intense acute stress
it can actually have
the opposite effect.
So we see the first
manifestation of the inverted
U, Impair excitability,
and impair memory,
and we know the expression
stress makes you stupid.
Then if we have repeated stress,
as I've already been saying,
you have what we call
adaptive plasticity,
the suppression of
neurogenesis and causing
remodeling or
shrinkage of dendrites,
or in some parts of the brain
actually the opposite, growth.
And I'll tell you about
that in a few moments.
Then with a severe crisis such
as a seizure, stroke, or a head
trauma the same players,
glucocorticoids and excitatory
amino acids actually cause the
permanent irreversible damage
in these conditions.
And so again the extreme
version of the inverted U,
brain aging over activity
of the glutamatergic system
and of the glucocorticoid
system contributes
to the speed of brain
aging and may even
play into the acceleration
of Alzheimer's disease.
But then finally we come
to the loss of resilience.
We know that after stress
these changes in the brain
architecture, which are
adaptive, if the stress is
over they should adjust.
It's not turning back
the clock, but adjusting
so they'll go back to more or
less the way they were before.
But when that doesn't
happen one may
have an anxiety disorder, or
depression, something that's
inappropriate for
the circumstances
and we have to intervene
with some external means,
with a drug, or with behavioral
interventions, or both.
Now a lot of this work that's
derived from animal models
has been extended
to the human brain
by people doing structural
and functional imaging.
We know the hippocampus
gets smaller
in prolonged major depression.
It also gets smaller in type-2
diabetes, which is often
associated with depression.
It's smaller in post-traumatic
stress disorder,
maybe as a precondition for the
disorder, and also as a result.
It is smaller and
Cushing's disease.
But there the good
news is if you
correct the hypercorticism the
hippocampus can recover over
six months to a year.
And both the mood regulation,
the volume change,
the cognitive dysfunction can
be at least partially reversed.
But you don't need
to have a disease,
because we know
there is a smaller
hippocampus with
prolonged chronic stress,
with chronic lag,
and lack of exercise,
and also with chronic
inflammation, which
is a condition of many of the
so-called non-communicable
diseases of modern life.
The good news is
that regular exercise
increases hippocampal volume.
Intense learning does the same.
And antidepressants do the same.
And one of the most effective
antidepressants is exercise.
An example of this from studies
of people in their 60s and 70s
who were largely couch
potatoes until they
were encouraged to
get off their duffs
and walk an hour a day five
out of seven days a week.
You can see on the
top the enlargement
of the hippocampus in six months
to a year, with improvements
in memory, and also changes in
the prefrontal cortex and blood
flow which made them more
efficient in decision
making and working memory.
So even as one ages these
changes are still possible
and that encourages
then to believe
that we can change the brain
with behavioral interventions
and not just with drugs.
Metabolic hormones
also affect the brain.
They enter the brain and
they have very positive
important effects.
For example, IGF-1
from the liver
actually goes into the
brain when we exercise.
And if you block the IGF-1
with antibodies exercise
does not stimulate neurogenesis.
So here's another example of
a peripheral acting hormone
that is essential
for a brain function.
Now, apologies for the
black, but on the left you
see that in the hippocampus and
the prefrontal cortex stress
causes dendrites to shrink.
And there is some resilience
possible in the healthy brain.
It also happens
in a place called
the medial amygdala, which is
important for social behavior.
But in the amygdala, especially
in the basolateral amygdala,
which is important for
anxiety, these dendrites expand
and the animal becomes more
anxious, more vigilant,
because the orbital frontal
cortex, which is involved
in vigilance also expands.
So here you have the
unbalanced brain architecture,
which is very
appropriate if you're
in a dangerous situation.
And so not only in
adulthood, but also kids
who have been
abused early in life
have a persistent
condition like this
where they are
much more vigilant
and their amygdala is much
more active as a result
of these early experiences.
We'll come back to
that very shortly.
So in adults the amygdala
is overactive in anxiety
and depression.
And effective treatment has
been done at Mass General
by Britta Holzel and Sara
Lazar of chronic anxiety
can actually reduce the
volume of the amygdala.
And overactive amygdala and
under-active prefrontal cortex
is associated with early signs
of cardiovascular disease.
And most interestingly if
you elevate glucocorticoids
at the right time, at the time
of trauma or right afterwards,
it actually reduces
PTSD symptoms.
So here glucocorticoids
have a protective role.
And that's very
important to emphasize,
because they're not bad guys.
They're there to do good.
In the prefrontal
cortex I was involved
in a study on medical
students during the course
of their studies, where
there were differing levels
of perceived stress.
The ones who were the
most stressed out actually
had an impaired circuitry
in their prefrontal cortex
and did worse on tests
of cognitive flexibility
than those who had
less perceived stress.
The good news is when they
had a month off for vacation
all these changes
reversed themselves.
They came back to normal.
So the young brain is
flexible in that way.
But studies that we've
done with John Morrison
on the prefrontal
cortex in animals
show that as the
animal gets older
it can show stress
responses, but it's
less resilient in recovering
unless we maybe help it out.
It's also affected by
circadian disruption.
And so of course, again,
maybe that can be treated.
So the final part is
really this whole question
of individual differences,
the effects of our gene
by environment,
epigenetic interactions,
experiences that happen
throughout the life course,
especially early in life.
And this concept of
long term influences
has been referred to as
biological embedding.
There are variations
on genes that
are referred to as context
sensitive alleles, sometimes
as orchid alleles,
because they can
for greater sensitivity
to either bad things
or good things.
Whereas the dandelions
are tougher and don't show
as much response.
And of course these
epigenetic modifications,
which are not confined
to early development,
this is a description
of all the things
that are happening
to brain plasticity
throughout the life course.
But they are particularly
potent early in life.
So for example,
studies of maternal
care currently by Michael
Meaney and colleagues.
Before that by Seymour
Levine and Victor Denenberg
showed that if mothers
nurture their pups
intensely they become more
laid back, less anxious,
and you can actually
cross foster pups
from a not so good mother
to a better mother,
and transfer behaviorally
these characteristics.
So the offspring, in
the case of the females,
become better
mothers so to speak.
And overall they
show less anxiety.
And others have shown that
animals that are less anxious
actually may live-- it's rats--
as much as 200 days longer
on the average.
So somehow this
gets under the skin
and can affect
the aging process.
Studies in our laboratory are
looking at early life stress,
where you disrupt the nest
so that the mother is not
taking care of her
pups adequately,
actually result
in the hippocampus
at least in the red
on the left when
you challenge these animals
with an acute stress the gene
expression is less
able to respond.
So there are less possibilities
to respond in an animal
that's received early life
stress than an animal that
hasn't.
And we're trying to
figure out what that means
in terms of later adaptation.
For example, treatment
resistance to depression
seems to be related in humans
to our early life, abuse,
and neglect.
So there are
developmental issues
for kids, which I'm
sure you are aware of.
Poverty and low
socioeconomic status
coupled with the
lack of stimulation
by the parent of--
verbally-- of the child
can lead to reduced
vocabulary and also changes
in learning ability.
There's a famous book
by Hart and Risley
called Meaningful Differences,
which follows this.
And now one of the
practices is to encourage
parents to verbally
stimulate their kids.
And they're even
devices to help kids
improve their
verbal communication
and improve the
kid's a vocabulary.
Chaos in the home in
poverty and because
of disruption of the family
can impair the development
of the prefrontal cortex.
So there's less self regulation.
It can lead to obesity, and
elevated blood pressure,
and cardiovascular reactivity
relatively early in life,
increased levels of
inflammatory tone
as indicated by
poor dental health.
And all of these
then are also, as I
said, because of the prefrontal
cortex, related to impaired
brain architecture and more
greater sensitivity to toxic
stress.
And then the adverse childhood
experiences studies of Felitta,
and Anda, and others actually
emphasize abuse and neglect
increasing not only mental
health disorders, but also
physical disorders,
cardiovascular disease,
diabetes, and so forth.
So just very quickly to
summarize some of the things
we know about early life
adversity and poverty.
It results in a smaller
hippocampus, low self-esteem,
and a greater risk
as a result for PTSD.
The amygdala is more
reactive, as I said, because
of these early
experiences, more vigilant,
and more likely then to
develop anxiety and depressive
disorders.
The prefrontal cortex
is more affected
so it is less able to help the
person self regulate, so there
is greater vulnerability
for substance abuse
for mood disorders, lesser
ability to plan and execute
the kind of life that one
needs in this modern society.
So what can one do about it?
Obviously prevention is
the most important thing.
The Nurse Family Partnership is
an example of an intervention
that helps parents have better
relationships with their kids
and improves, as demonstrated
over 20 years of observation,
does improve childhood outcomes.
But as I've also said when
bad things have happened
there are things that
are possible illustrating
that we can change the
brain with experience.
One of them I've
already mentioned
is regular physical activity.
I've also mentioned the
mindfulness-based stress
reduction.
If you reduce
anxiety effectively,
you can decrease
amygdala volume.
And this may be anxiety that's
a result of some early life
condition.
And finally the most important
thing of course for anybody
is finding meaning
and purpose in life.
And social support and
integration are very important.
And programs like the Experience
Corps getting, in this case
elderly volunteers
involved in taking
care of elementary school
kids in the classroom.
The health of the
volunteers is better
because there have increased
physical activity, increased
social interactions, and
they're doing something
that has meaning and purpose.
And there are studies by
Barbara Fredrickson among others
showing that eudaimonia
or meaning and purpose
actually can reduce the overall
inflammatory tone in the body.
So the wisdom of the body, which
is a term that originated here
in Harvard, is
really something that
tells us, let's pay
attention to our bodies
and don't let our lifestyle
push us over the edge.
And we know that
our modern lifestyle
can work against
what is sensible
and produce allostatic load.
So with that I'm going
to turn it back to Linn.
-So from the
Rockefeller perspective
to the clinical
perspective, here
is a family physician
encountering a lady.
And here is Helena.
She's 54 years old and she
is married with two children.
She has low education and
her new general practitioner,
a family physician, finds a
lot of long standing problems
in her medical record, typical
chronic complex diseases,
hypertension, diabetes type 2,
overweight, hypothyroidosis,
chronic widespread pain,
that's one of the medically
unexplained problems.
She has recurrent
airway infections
and is bordering on
chronic pulmonary disease,
irritable bowel syndrome,
depression with anxiety,
and probably she osteoporosis.
She hasn't been
measured, but she
has had a fracture that
shouldn't really have happened
at the kind of accident.
And she takes from seven to
10 prescription drugs daily,
depending on what
she and her physician
are trying out to work
on her pain problem.
And she still smokes
despite advice.
And then the medical students
are told by me and others
to encounter patients from a
biopsychosocial perspective.
And it's really a question
what is in there package.
The perspective of
a biomedicine today
is what we have decided
to call silo medicine.
It's a nasty word.
We didn't invent it ourselves.
We found it first time in JAMA,
the Journal of the American
Medical Association.
But we adopted it immediately.
The kind of the list of the
problems that Helena has
can be compared to silos.
Each of the silos
has its own life
in a sense culminating in
clinical guidelines for each
of these diseases.
And each disease is taken
as something separate.
The problem is that this
fragmenting approach
doesn't really work
very well in practice.
Family physicians complain
about guideline overflow.
A typical guideline for
like diabetes type 2
coming out in Norway now is 250
pages, for one single problem.
And the idea that one size
fits all, when to treat,
how to treat, et cetera.
And the worst part
of it is actually
the kind of uncoordinated poly
pharmacy that it leads to.
Because if you treat
each of the diseases
with the drugs pertaining
to the disease,
and the patient has four or
five diseases at the same time,
it can become quite toxic.
And it is a terrible truth
that death from side effects
and toxic interaction
between drugs
is actually on the
top 10 list of courses
of death in the Western world.
I shall not tell you where
on this ranking you find it
but it's quite high and
definitely on the top 10 list.
The strange thing is that
people with multimorbity,
that is people like Helena
with several chronic diseases
at the same time,
they have existed
I think as long as
humankind has existed.
But it has taken such a long
time for advanced medicine
to start really
investigating the issue.
Here you can see two
major publications
from the European
side of the Atlantic.
The British Medical
Journal had a cover page
and The Lancet had a
fantastic paper in 2012.
I will get back to that
about the epidemiology
on multimorbidity.
And here you can
see an editorial
asking us to rise to the
challenge of multimorbitiy.
What are we actually looking at?
What is the problem when so
many diseases tend to cluster
in one and the same person?
Is it just by accident?
What is going on?
We have to take a closer look.
And then what we already know
and we don't need any more
research actually
to prove this is
that there is a very
strong social gradient
in multimorbidity.
This is the Scottish
paper from The Lancet.
And you can see here
that at all ages
if you compare the richest
strata of the population,
that's the black line, with the
most deprived people you can
see that at least in the
younger and middle aged
populations there is
a major difference.
It will actually be a question
of doubling the prevalence
if you are deprived.
So there is something associated
with social realities here.
In a sense we have
enough knowledge
about co and multimorbidity
in the world.
But in order to make a
difference where you live,
you have to make
some local research
as well to have something
to throw to the politicians.
So we have made some
local research and Bruce
as you can see from that
author list has been
so kind to help us with it.
We have a population study
called HUNTS study in Norway.
It's one of the
biggest in the world.
This particular paper is based
on about 48,000 participants
in this affluent
relatively homogeneous
Norwegian population.
And you have a list of
self-reported diseases
to the left.
And I am not going into
the methodological pros
and cons of this approach.
But you can see a
list of diseases.
If you look at this column
or the horizontal bar
you can see the number of people
with that particular disease.
And if the person has only that
disease he or she will be blue.
If another disease on the list
is present it will be red.
If two or more diseases are
present it will be green.
And if three or more it
will be a violet color.
And as you can see it's
far more common to have
two or three diseases
than only the one disease.
Some multimorbidity is the
rule and not the exception.
And this has not been
accounted for in medicine
and this is really serious from
a primary care perspective.
And if you try to find out
what diseases are combined
with what diseases
you can just as well
look at the starry night.
It's very hard actually to
figure out the constellations,
even though you
know they're there.
This is our PhD Candidate
Margaret from Iceland
who has chosen this metaphor.
So the question is what
is going on actually?
And I will go back
to the year where
I think most of the knowledge
that we are building on
in Trondheim came out.
Of course this has long
roots and this is not
where it started.
But here comes some very
important publications,
at least from my perspective.
The Adverse Childhood
Experience study
from the Californian group
mentioned by Bruce came out.
And from this moment on we know
that there is a dose response
relationship between adversity
in childhood and adult
disease and multimorbidity.
And this has been shown in
other studies as well later.
My previous mentor
Anna Luise Kirkengen
who is a Norwegian German
professor in general practice,
she defended her
thesis the same year
based on qualitative
in-depth interviews
with people who had suffered
childhood sexual abuse.
Its a fantastic book.
It was released a few years
later in Kluwer Academic Press.
And it tells how
people with abuse
experience complex and
unexplainable to medicine
kinds of health problems,
as well as the health
problems that medicine knows
and thinks it can explain.
And the third thing
that happened in 1998
was actually that first
Bruce McEwen published
the allostatic load
paper in New England
that you started out with.
And from my perspective,
these three very different
approaches, the clinical
epidemiological study
from California, the
in-depth interview study
from this Norwegian population
by Kirkengen, and Bruce McEwen,
it's my golden triangle.
It's rare.
Within these limits I can
see so much happening now
and I am wondering what is
the best word to connect
and I think the best
word is embodiment.
And that is a word I have
not at all invented myself,
because that word has
actually been invented here
at Harvard, Nancy Krieger.
I have never met her, but
this is a fantastic paper.
And I want to read to you
the sentences that are here
because if there is anything
that rings true to the family
physician in the front line
it is this insight that Nancy
Krieger presents.
I don't know how she
could do it, because it's
so beautiful written.
And she says the following,
"Recognizing that we as humans
are simultaneously social
beings and biological organisms,
the notion of embodiment
advances three critical
claims-- Bodies tell stories
about and cannot be studied
divorced from the
conditions of our existence.
Bodies tell stories that
often, but not always,
much peoples stated accounts.
And bodice tell stories that
people cannot or will not tell
either because they
are unable, forbidden,
or choose not to tell."
This is the clinical
manifestation
of difficult lives and
adverse experiences.
And I think this is something
we have to bring into medicine.
I'm struggling to teach my
medical students this and also
their postgraduate
GPs in our area,
because if we start really
understanding this and talking
to people along
these lines medicine
will become so much more
effective in the front line.
Stories.
I was collecting
evidence for a long time
mainly in my evening time.
And I finally got
around, together
with my mentor Ana
Luise and a professor
in immunology and
microbiology Alling Ulvestad
to write a paper,
originally in Norwegian,
but it is also translated.
And we chose the title, "The
Human Biology-- Saturated
With Experience."
And I think it was
such a hard job
to collect all this
evidence and put it together
in a theoretically
sound manner and I
had to fight with the
journal to have it accepted
as an original piece of work.
Because if you are
researching evidence
that somebody else has collected
that is just something,
it doesn't really count.
But I think we have so
much primary research,
we have to look at it
and put it together.
We can't have everybody
collect more original data.
We have to look at the data
that is already out there.
And there's so
much going on now.
It is a fantastic time to
be part of this evolution.
We have another little study
from this HUNT population where
we were able to
introduce one question
about subjective
experiences of childhood.
And we have been
looking at how this is
associated with multimorbidity.
And we have had the idea
that allostatic load is
the underlying mediator
between experiences
of childhood and adult disease.
And as you can see here
again Bruce has helped us.
In this video you can
see a lot of diseases,
the same self-reported
diseases again,
in a somewhat different list.
And we have the prevalence
of each of these diseases
along the x-axis.
And then we have the different
colors here representing
different levels of
childhood experience,
from very good, which is
dark blue, to very difficult,
which is the red color.
And what you can see for
almost all diseases, not
all of them, not cancer
and not hypertension
for some strange reasons,
but for all the others
there is this dose response
relationship, which shows you
that a difficult childhood
just subjectively
reported in one question is a
predictor of a much higher risk
of disease than otherwise.
And I use the
thyroid as an example
because I don't
think people are used
to thinking about
thyroid disease
as typically related
to your childhood.
But there is something about
it as Bruce was mentioning
in his case, the woman with
the immunological disease,
the immune system is part
of this whole adaptation.
So what I have prepared when
I teach my students and also
actually people with
much less education
I have stolen this
figure from Bruce.
He knows it and he
has accepted it.
And I am asking permission
to talk about allostatic load
as a balance between
drains and gains.
The path of genetic part, the
stress, the detrimental things
are on the left hand side,
d the life sustaining
and resilience things are
on the right hand side.
And since we are living in a
dualistic medical world I am
dividing the medical literature
into mental and physical
because I cannot make up
for that even though we
shouldn't think that way.
We have to work
with what we have.
And then I add all
the world literature.
And it won't get
worse than this.
But here you have like
a two times two table.
And you can see that
you can somehow sort out
lots of the evidence that's
out there because there are
many individual
papers investigating,
for instance, overwhelming
responsibilities.
We are at the top left.
That's my name for
having a spouse who
gets Alzheimer's
disease and you care
for the person for many,
many years with love,
but it's also a
draining experience.
Or you have a chronically
disabled child.
You want to do the
job, but it's tough.
And I call this
overwhelming responsibility.
And we know it has an
impact on telomere function,
on allostatic load, et cetera.
And you can read
the world literature
and put the pixels
into this picture.
We know that injustice
is bad for people.
The Whitehall study has
shown that people who
experience subjective
unfairness,
they feel maltreated
and they get
more disease, and more
cardiovascular disease
than others.
And you have the physical
things that are well known
and then you have the
more gaining sides,
on the right hand side and
you find exercise and all
this sleep and all this.
And I think this is an
opening for discussing
in the clinical situation with
patients where can we start.
It's not obvious
that you should start
attacking smoking in
somebody who has not
been able to stop before.
You could mention it, but
perhaps you could rather just
talk about meaningful
activities or how is it
to carry this responsibility.
The whole point is
that I suspect very m
and I think I'm not
alone, that when
the drains are much
heavier than the gains that
is where you start fueling
up under multimorbidity.
So instead of looking at disease
from a pure silo perspective.
We could perhaps use
the volcano metaphor.
And I'm talking about risk.
Of course you can
become multimorbidity
without having any adverse
experiences in life.
I'm talking about
added risk here.
And the idea is that
allostatic overload
is a common denominator that can
fuel up under so many diseases.
Once you get one
you have increased
risk of several diseases.
Bruce I think you
took part in writing
about the biology
of disadvantage.
That's your term or
your milieu has that.
Michael Marmot speaks about
the causes of the causes.
And Paul Farmer
here from Harvard
speaks about
pathologies of power.
I'm not sure if
he's really speaking
about allostatic
overload, but it must
be part of the same picture.
So we have some very
good terms that we
can use to try to mediate
and express this insight.
And now comes the clue
to the whole thing.
You didn't say much
about it Bruce,
but in theory this can all
be measured and monitored.
And that is exactly the ambition
of personalized medicine
now, to monitor
what's happening.
To be able to predict and
perhaps prevent things
from going bad.
And as I told you, I can see
a best case and worst case
scenario now from this idea
that we understand so much
of the mechanisms.
And if you look at
this paper from 2011
this is about systems
personalized medicine.
It is written by 64 system
biologists and one GP, who
actually was president
of the world association
at the time for
general practitioners.
And here is the idea
that the vision now
is to be let each patient be
surrounded by a virtual cloud
of billions of data points.
And it's going to be unbiased
by classification systems.
And we will have new biomarkers.
These people have understood
that multimorbidity
is an artifact to a certain
extent of the way we
think about disease.
There is something
going on much deeper.
So the point is they
have really understood
many of the flaws of modern
medical thinking, which
is a good thing.
The question is only can we only
solve it by measuring things
or can we actually find out
without all those measurements.
The iPOP is the integrated
personalized omics profiling.
And here you have a billion
data points at several levels
from the genome, via
the epigenetic markers,
the metelome, and
you go all the way
to the metabolic
various components
that you can measure
in the person's blood.
And you do this over a lifetime.
You start before the child is
born perhaps with the mother
and you go through like every
three months or something
and you monitor the iPOP.
And we are actually arriving
at this very soon now
because we have all
this technology.
We can measure, we can
combine then big data.
Google has already established
its baseline study.
Apple has this kit and they
remind us that our iPhones,
they are actually
powerful medical tools.
So we are going into
an era now where
we can measure and
monitor ourselves
to an increasing extent.
And here is the point where
I think Greek mythology can
come to our help.
Are we going in the
right direction?
What questions
should we raise now?
Is if the narciss-ome
that is being invented?
Is there a risk that we can
drown like the poor Narcissus?
We can just become so infatuated
by our own mirror image
that the molecular me will
be just what we can see,
and we can forget all around us.
We can forget about education,
about equality, about justice.
We can just take
care of ourselves
and monitor ourselves.
A PhD student of
ours, Henrik Vogt,
has written a fantastic
paper that recently came out
about the idea that
now we are supposed
to quantify our health.
We're not only going
to measure ourselves
when we feel bad or sick but
we should quantify and monitor
our health according
to systems medicine.
And here is another
paper by the same guy
where we put the ultimate
question to the test.
"Getting personal--
can systems medicine
integrate scientific and
humanistic conceptions
of the patient?"
Can we by measuring
everything get to the point
where we don't need to
speak to people anymore.
And the conclusion is ultimately
systems medicine may also
have to recognize that
to faithfully model
a human being it's necessary
to be a human being.
It took us 10 pages to
get to that conclusion.
And you might laugh,
but actually there
are people who are really
selling this idea that this
is all you need.
And then a bit of
Greek history again.
The Oracle of Apollo, the temple
of healing also in old Greece,
it had this inscription
at the door, know thyself.
I can't say it in Greek.
It's something like
[SPEAKING GREEK].
I don't know how they spoke.
Anyway, it was know thyself.
And as our PhD student
has pointed out
that is something different
from knowing thy selfie.
And that is actually
the end of the talk.
There is a lot that we
haven't spoken about,
especially the nature
of these measurements.
I can just promise
they are there.
And the question
is how are we going
to handle this fantastic
insight, the political nature
of medicine.
We know about the pathologies
of power, the disadvantages,
and all this.
Are we going to
measure ourselves
out of it or are we going to
act on a more political level.
That's the main question.
And here are the
acknowledgments coming.
Thank you.